herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid wir schauen
hier heute auf den Besuch des
ukrainischen Präsidenten volodimir
selenski in Washington dort dringt der
auf eine Fortsetzung der
usmitärhilfen für die Ukraine geplant
für den heutigen Tag waren unter anderem
Gespräche mit Vertretern beider
kongresskammern und später steht noch
ein Treffen mit US-Präsident Joe Biden
an es ist bereits zelenskis dritter
Besuch in Washington und lass uns mal
auf die Bilder vom Dezember letzten
Jahres gucken so wurde zelenski damals
im Kongress empfangen wir sehen Standing
Ovations an allen Seiten sogar
Jubelrufe und bei diesem Besuch heute
steht ziemlich viel auf dem Spiel denn
die oppositionellen usreublikaner die
haben in der vergangenen Woche ein von
beiden vorgelegtes Finanzpaket im
Volumen von 106 Milliarden Dollar
abgelehnt und innerhalb dieses
finanzpakets waren auch ukrainehilfen in
Höhe von 61,4 Milliarden Dollar die sind
jetzt geblockt deswegen fragen wir heute
was kann zelenski mit diesem Besuch
heute erreichen was sind die Gründe für
das Zögern der Republikaner und wie
blickt eigentlich Russland auf dieses
Treffen und wir fragen entscheidet sich
in Washington der Krieg das alles
besprechen wir heute mit
us-korrespondentin und meiner Kollegin
Claudia Bates in Washington und mit
Politikwissenschaftlerin dr SAR paragung
und wie immer hier bei heute live auch
mit euch da draußen vor den Screens wenn
ihr Fragen zum Thema habt die ich hier
mit den Expertin diskutieren soll oder
ihr einfach eure Meinung zum Thema mit
uns teilen wollt dann schreibt uns sie
immer gerne entweder hier im Youtube
Chat oder per Mail an die eingeblendete
Mailadresse so und damit wir jetzt für
diese Gespräche für diesen Stream alle
auf dem gleichen Stand sind hat sich
mein Kollege Christian sem mal
angeschaut wie eigentlich die letzten
Besuche in den USA von selenski so
ausgegangen
sind diese Reise könnte entscheidend
sein für die weitere Existenz seines
Heimatlandes Präsident selenski auf
Werbetour in den USA die Ukraine braucht
dringend neue Militärhilfen überzeugen
muss selenski vor allem die Republikaner
im
US-Kongress die Ukrainer haben nicht
aufgegeben und werden nicht aufgeben wir
wissen was zu tun ist und Sie können auf
die Ukraine zählen und genauso hoffen
wir dass wir auch auf Sie zählen können
die USA sind der wichtigste Unterstützer
der Ukraine im Kampf gegen den
russischen Angriffskrieg doch weitere
Milliardenhilfen für die Ukraine lehnen
die Republikaner ab fordern stattdessen
mehr Mittel für den Schutz der
ussüdgrenze die beiden Regierung will
die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen wenn wir der Aggression des
kremmels heute nicht die Stirn bieten
wenn wir andere potenzielle aggressuren
nicht abschrecken werden wir nur noch
mehr Aggressionen hervorrufen noch mehr
Blut vergießen undch noch mehr
Chaos als selenski vor einem Jahr in die
USA reiste wurde er noch gefeiert als
Held des Widerstands gegen den
russischen Aggressor seit Beginn der
Invasion im Februar 22 haben die USA
bereits mehr als 44 Milliarden Dollar an
Militärhilfen bereitgestellt ein Jahr
später muss selenski um neue Hilfen
betteln in Moskau schaut man sich das
genüsslich
an es ist sehr wichtig dass jeder
versteht dass Dutzende Milliarden
EP ihr nicht zu irgendeinem Erfolg auf
dem Schlachtfeld verholfen
haben selenski warnt noch mal wer
profitiert wenn die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine schwindet und sagt
Verzögerung dieser Hilfen sind wahr
gewordene Träume für Vladimir
Putin ja eine vermeintliches schwinden
dieser Hilfen besprechen wir jetzt mit
meiner Kollegin Claudia BZ die uns live
aus Washington zugeschaltet ist guten
Abend
Claudia Claudia der Präsident selenski
der kam heute zu einem Gespräch hinter
verschlossenen Türen mit den
Senatorinnen und Senatoren zusammen das
Treffen dauerte mehr als eine Stunde wie
ist die Stimmung heute in Washington was
ist da
rausgekommen genau also der Kontrast
könnte überhaupt nicht größer sein zu
dem was wir gerade gesehen haben ne ihr
habt es berichtet vor einem Jahr wird er
empf wie ein Held die Senatoren und
Abgeordneten aus dem Repräsentantenhaus
stehen auf und applaudieren es wird eine
Flagge überreicht und davon heute nichts
also davon ist nichts geblieben sondern
es war ein Treffen hinter verschlossenen
Türen man hat selenski nur über die
Flure im Kapitol laufen sehen aber es
gab keinen Applaus es gab keinen großen
Auftritt sondern es waren ganz
schwierige Gespräche die jetzt zu führen
sind nach dieser langen Zeit und wo die
Stimmung doch eben einfach schlechter
geworden ist insgesamt was die Ukraine
und ihre Fortschritte
angeht insofern es geht für selenski
tatsächlich um alles und dieses Paket um
was es jetzt hier im Kongress geht
das ist ein großes Paket was
unterschiedliche Hilfen enthält nicht
nur für die Ukraine aber für die Ukraine
60 Milliarden Dollar und die sind nicht
nur fürs Militär sondern auch für den
Haushalt das heißt es geht auch darum
dafür zu sorgen dass die Ukraine als
Land weiter funktionieren kann dass
weiter gehandelt werden kann dort
politisch also insofern war das ein
wahnsinnig wichtiges Treffen und deshalb
hat selenski da noch mal sehr sehr
dringlich zum einen beschrieben wie die
militärische Situation im Moment ist und
wie dringend er diese militärische Hilfe
braucht und zum anderen hat er natürlich
den großen Bogen geschlagen auch für die
Amerikaner und noch mal sehr
eindringlich gesagt dass es eben Putin
wäre der profitieren würde wenn wenn die
USA der wichtigste Partner von der von
selenski Zaudern würden es gab
unterschiedliche Einschätzung dann des
Gesprächs hinterher natürlich die bei
den Demokraten rennt er ja sozusagen
offene Türen ein die hielten es für ein
sehr kraftvolles treffen ich zitiere mal
den demokratischen Senator Chuck Schumer
der gesagt hat dass selenski beschrieben
habe die Ukraine könne gewinnen
weiterhin aber sie bräuchte eben die
Hilfe der USA um zu gewinnen und er
hätte auch klar gemacht was es bedeuten
würde wenn Putin gewinnt und wie
gefährlich das eben auch für die USA
wäre das wä ist hier schon so ein
bisschen in den Hintergrund getreten äh
dass es ja auch um das eben nicht nur
für die Freiheit der Ukraine gekämpftd
sondern auch um die Freiheit der USA und
ähm der
republikanische Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses dagegen meinte ähm
im Prinzip ja äh man ist ja auch für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine aber
äh man will doch genauer gucken wo
fließen diese Milliarden eigentlich hin
es gäbe keinen genauen Plan es gebe
keine genaue Strategie die Regierung
beiden wäre den Amerikanern viele viele
Antworten schuldig und insofern um auf
deine Frage zurückzukommen ne ähm was
gibt es für Ergebnisse äh also
Ergebnisse gibt es insofern nicht als
die Parteien sich hier eben immer noch
verhagt haben ineinander äh und nicht so
ganz klar ist wie sie da wieder
rauskommen wollen
okay also wir haben auf der einen Seite
überzeugte Demokraten DemokratInnen die
selenski aber eh schon überzeugt hatte
auf der anderen Seite weiterhin zögernde
Republikaner und Republikanerin jetzt
kam in unserem Beitrag gerade das Thema
Südgrenze der USA auf was anscheinend
ein Grund für die Republikaner ist
kannst du uns noch mal im Detail sagen
was die Republikaner gegen dieses
Hilfspaket haben bzw wo sie hin wollen
was sie quasi als Fokus sehen der mit
US-amerikanischem Geld verfolgt werden
sollte
ja genau also das hat eine gewisse
traurige Ironie wenn man so will dass
wenn das Paket über die ukrainehilfe für
sich einfach isoliert zur Abstimmung
gestellt werden würde dann hätte es eine
überparteiliche Mehrheit nicht alle
würden dafür stimmen aber es hätte
insgesamt eine Mehrheit aber die
Republikaner haben gerade jetzt bei der
Ukraine eine Möglichkeit gesehen die äh
den den Demokraten etwas abzuverlangen
gerade weil die Ukraine so wichtig ist
gerade weil der außenpolitische
Erfolg auch für Präsident Biden so
wichtig ist und wofür die Ukraine eben
steht auch für den Kampf von Freiheit
gegen Autokratie gegen Diktatur ein ein
uramerikanisches Anliegen und ein
wichtiges Anliegen von Präsident beiden
also gerade deshalb sehen die
Republikaner jetzt die Möglichkeit die
Demokraten unter Druck zu setzen und
Forderungen durchzusetzen die Ihnen
besonders wichtig sind das ist hier sie
sprechen von einer Krise an der
Südgrenze es kommen tatsächlich jeden
Tag 8000 10.000 Menschen äh über diese
Grenze aus Mexiko illegal äh ins Land
und das ist schon lange ein riesiges
Thema und seit Jahrzehnten soll es im
Grunde eine Reform dieser
Migrationspolitik Einwanderungspolitik
geben und das ist nie gelungen und jetzt
ist im Grunde das Anliegen sozusagen
durch den Druck den man aufbauen kann äh
im Hoppler hoopverfahren äh die
Demokraten dazu zu bringen dort
schärfere Regeln ein zu führen also z.B
viel stärkere Abschiebungen
möglicherweise Leute auch in Haft nehmen
bis sie abgeschoben werden die
asylregeln sehr stark zu verschärfen nun
sind das alles Dinge die die Demokraten
so ohne weiteres nicht befürworten
können auch wenn sie was machen wollen
für die Sicherheit der Grenze das ist
schon insgesamt sieht man dass das so
nicht weitergehen kann aber gleichzeitig
sind die Demokraten natürlich damit
angetreten äh eine humanere
Einwanderungspolitik äh machen zu wollen
als die Vorgängerregierung äh insofern
können die Demokraten da nicht ohne
weiteres mitgehen äh und nun ist die
Frage sozusagen wer bewegt sich zuerst
ja also selenski müsste im Grunde
entweder die Demokraten äh dazu bringen
diese verschärften einwanderungsregeln
anzunehmen oder er müsste die
Republikaner dazu bringen dass über das
ukraineepaket allein abgestimmt wird und
beides ist überhaupt nicht absehbar
insofern wird sich das nur
regeln lassen über weitere Verhandlungen
und die Frage ist halt in welchem
Zeithorizont weil die Abgeordneten Ende
dieser Woche in den Weihnachtsurlaub
gehen möchten ja also eine ziemlich
festgefahrene Situation jetzt soll sich
ja innerhalb der nächsten Stunde auch
noch selenski und beiden treffen bzw vor
die Öffentlichkeit treten was erwartet
man denn von diesem Treffen wird es da
Überraschendes zu hören
geben also das wird mit Sicherheit eine
große Show von Einheit und Stärke und
und beides ist auch wichtig also die die
Einigkeit ist wichtig als Signal in jede
Richtung in nach hinein in die USA
natürlich noch mal welche Bedeutung die
Ukraine hat in die Ukraine auch als
Motivation für die Menschen dort
dass sie von ihrem wichtigsten Partner
nicht alleine gelassen werden sondern
dass es weitergeht und dass sie dass sie
Hilfe bekommen wie auch immer dass
jedenfalls die USA an ihrer Seite stehen
dann ist die Einigkeit auch wichtig in
Richtung Europa in Richtung NATO ins
esamt wo Präsident Biden ja maßgeblich
ein Bündnis geschmiedet hat was jetzt
schon lang hält und was natürlich auf
Strecke auch noch halten muss
und insofern diese Einigkeit auch nach
dort zu signalisieren ist wichtig und
zuletzt auch noch sozusagen weiter
entfernt in die Welt ein bisschen nach
China ist es wichtig diese Einigkeit zu
zeigen um auch zu zeigen die die die
westlichen Demokratien funktionieren was
ja angezweifelt wird von Diktatoren und
Autokraten zu zeigen die westlichen
Demokratien funktionieren das ist eins
der wichtigsten Anliegen von Präsident
Biden äh in seiner Präsidentschaft und
das andere ist auch Abschreckung also äh
natürlich will man auch zeigen man ist
stark das habe ich gesagt eine Stärke
Einigkeit und Stärke Stärke auch in dem
Sinn dass eben nicht andere Autokraten
oder Diktatoren auf die Idee kommen
ähnliches zu tun also insofern
werden wir sicherlich äh sehr
harmonische Bilder sehen nachher äh und
große Worte in denen es wirklich ums
große und ganze auch gehen wird wir sind
gespannt vielen dank dir Claudia dass du
meine Fragen beantwortet hast und alles
Gute für dich nach
Washington danke schön
Victoria so und wenn beiden und selenski
später vielleicht prognostiziert von
meiner Kollegin auf das beger picture
gucken dann machen wir das jetzt hier
auch noch mal ich sehe schon ihr habt
auch einige Fragen die wir gleich noch
diskutieren können wir gucken jetzt mal
darauf was dieser Tag eigentlich für
einen Einfluss auf den gesamten Krieg
hat auf die gesamte geopolitische Lage
in der wir uns befinden und wir gucken
uns auch an was Russland zu diesem Tag
sagt und das bespreche ich jetzt mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin dr Sarah pagung
die mir zugeschalet ist guten Abend Frau
pagung guten Abend Frau pagung ich frage
auch noch mal sie wie entscheidend ist
denn jetzt dieser dritte Besuch
selenskis in den USA für den Krieg wir
haben schon gesehen die Reaktion in den
USA der Empfang ist eine andere stimm
als von dem Jahr wie entscheidend ist
das wirklich für die Realität auf dem
Kriegsfeld also es ist sicherlich nicht
so dass dieses eine Paket jetzt über
wohl oder WE in der Ukraine
unterscheidet dass die Herausforderung
das Problem ist viel mehr dass es eben
auch um diese kleinen Schritte geht also
wir sehen dass die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine im Westen insgesamt also in
Europa auch den USA ganz
unterschiedlichen Gründen stärker in
Frage gestellt wird und da schaut man
natürlich sehr genau auf jede kleine
Entscheidung und oder vielleicht auch
gar nicht so kleine Entscheidung und vor
allen Dingen auch darauf wie sie
getroffen wird wie schnell wird sie
getroffen mit welcher Einigkeit wird sie
getroffen und mit Blick auch auf die
anstehenden US-Wahlen im nächsten Jahr
und einer möglichen Rückkehr von Trump
oder eines anderen er Ukraine
briritischen Republikaner stellt sich
natürlich die Frage wie feit geht hier
von eine Signalwirkung aus und deswegen
würde ich sagen es ist eben sehr wichtig
dass dieses Paket
durchgeht jetzt hat ja meine Kollegin
gerade gesagt es ist eigentlich aufgrund
dieser vertragten Lage der verschieden
Interessen die da gerade in diesem Paket
auch kollidieren gar nicht so absehbar
wann mit einer Entscheidung zu rechnen
ist was glauben Sie denn sie wann wann
könnte man mit einer Entscheidung für
dieses Paket
rechnen also ich fürchte dass sich diese
Entscheidung ins neue Jahr verschieben
wird also es wurde ja schon gesagt dass
jetzt eben einfach die Weihnachtsferien
anstehen eben auch für die für den
Kongress für den Senat für für das Haus
in den USA und eben die Frage ist ob das
vorher noch noch durchkommt und es wäre
eben durchaus wichtig und eine Signal
Wirkung wenn das passieren würde wir
sehen aber eben in den USA dass die
Entscheidung zur Unterstützung der
Ukraine immer mehr verwoben wird in
innenpolitische Auseinandersetzung auch
als Hebel genutzt wird für innenpitische
Auseinandersetzung und daher würde ich
fast damit rechnen dass ich das leider
noch etwas verzögern wird ja apropos
innenpolitische Themen innenpolitische
Debatten hier schreibt gerade jemand in
unsere Kommentare wenn sich der Krieg
weiter in die Länge zieht und dann auch
noch Trump die Wahlen 2025 2024 ist das
äh gewinnt ist der Ofen in der Ukraine
aus ich hoffe es kommt anders gehen sie
damit das ist ja eine Stile
these also ich glaube nicht dass es zu
so einem abrupten Ende oder zu zu so
einem zu einer sousagen sehr auf einem
Punkt fixierten Entscheidung in der
Ukraine kommen wird aber die Sorge ist
in der Tat und die Teile ich an sich ähm
wenn die USA sich möglicherweise
zurückziehen oder zumindest die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine
verkleinern dass das eben auch
Auswirkung in Europa haben wird und was
wir eben sehen ist dass die Ukraine
finanziell vor allen Dingen aber von der
militärische Unterstützung her eben
abhängig ist vom Westen und dass das am
Ende also dieser Krieg eben kein Sprint
ist sondern Marathon und dass man dafür
sorgen muss dass sie Unterstützung
langfristig hält das heißt nicht nur
jetzt nicht nur nächstes Jahr bis den
US-Wahlen sondern auch noch
möglicherweise längerfristig darüber
hinaus ja und dieses Thema was die
us-hilfen und die Entscheidung über
us-hilfen eigentlich mit der restlichen
Unterstützung aus dem Westen macht äh es
interessiert auch die User und Userin
hier fragt jemand sollten die us-hilfen
ausfallen kann will die EU das
Auffangen also die EU ist sicherlich
momentan dazu nicht in der Lage aufgrund
von Mitgliedern die ja Hilfen blockieren
auch ein weiter voranschreiben von
europäischen Hilfen blockieren also vor
allen Dingen natürlich die natürlich
Ungarn aber nicht nur das heißt ich
glaube nicht dass Europa das aktuell
auffangen kann die Frage ist sollte die
Unterstützung in den USA wackeln was
macht dann Europa als Europa ähm
geopolitisch gereif genug um dann in die
Bresche zu sprengen oder ist es
eigentlich am Ende das Gegenteil und man
lässt dann auch hier
nach ja ähm wir haben jetzt über eine
gewisse kriegsmütigkeit in den USA
gesprochen zumindest in Teilen und das
sind ja auch Debatten die wir in einigen
Ländern Europas führen die wir zum Teil
auch in Deutschland
führen lassen Sie uns mal in die Ukraine
gucken die sind ja betroffen was
schätzen Sie denn ein wie ungebrochen
ist den dieser jaah am Anfang sehr viel
zitierte und sehr hochgehaltene äh
verteidigungswille der Ukrainer und
Ukrainerin
derzeit also ich glaube dass der
verteidigungswille nach wie vor hoch ist
auch weil es eigentlich keine
Alternative gibt für die für die Ukraine
man sieht in den von der Kiever
Regierung kontrollierten und geschützten
Gebieten e ganz genau was im von
Russland in den von Russland besetzten
Gebieten passiert und das möchte man
natürlich verhindern nichtdestotrotz ist
es natürlich so dass die gescheiterte
Offensive der monatelang und ja
eigentlich jetzt fast jahrelange Krieg
natürlich einen Preis hat für die
Bevölkerung für die einzelnen Personen
ganz vielleicht der persönlich oder
familiär aber auch im größeren Bild und
dass das natürlich auch dazu beiträgt
dass man sich fragt wie soll das
eigentlich weitergehen und wie lange
kann man das Durchhalten insbesondere
jetzt wo man sieht dass die
Unterstützung im Westen zumindest in
Frage ellt wird also ich würde sagen es
ist auch für die Ukraine eine durchaus
nicht leichte
Situation lassen sie uns vielleicht noch
mal auf die Gründe gucken dafür dass
sich das Klima gegenüber der Ukraine
gegenüber selenski so verändert hier
fragt jetzt z.B jemand auf Youtube
welchen Einfluss wird der Krieg auf die
Wahlen in den USA haben wenn wir jetzt
vielleicht mal so ein bisschen in die
Glaskugel gucken auf den Wahlkampf 2024
in den USA welche Rolle wird dieser
Krieg dort
spielen also ich glaube nicht und das
ist jetzt natürlich wirklich bisschen
tig sein mit der Prognose ich glaube
nicht dass er einen ganz
ausschlaggebenden Grund spielen wird d
was wir in Wahlen generell aber
insbesondere auch in uswahen eigentlich
immer wieder sehen ist dass
innenpolitische Themen die wichtigsten
oder die führenden Themen auch im
Wahlkampf sind es ist natürlich aber so
dass ich insbesonderung das zeigen ja
Umfragen unter republikanischen Wähler
und WählerInnen eine größere Ukraine
Skepsis oder eine Skepsis gegenüber der
militärischen und finanziellen
Unterstützung für die Ukraine breit
macht und daher würde ich sagen es ist
schon sehr wahrscheinlich dass ein
republikanischer Kandidat Kandidatin
diese Skepsis aufgreifen wird und es
auch zum Thema machen wird aber ich
glaube nicht dass das Wahl entscheidend
sein wird jetzt haben wir in Deutschland
und auch in vielen anderen Teilen der
Welt nächstes Jahr ein superwahl ja aber
in Deutschland haben wir zumindest mal
die Landtagswahlen im Osten in den neuen
Bundesländern aber auch die Europawahl
wird sich da dieser Schift dann auch
Richtung innenpolitische Probleme
Thematiken verschieben welche Rolle
glauben sie wird der ukrainekrieg in
diesen Wahlen
spielen also ich glaube auch hier
insbesondere wenn wir auf die
Landtagswahlen schauen glaube ich nicht
dass es ein ausschlaggebendes Thema sein
wird aber es wird sicherlich eine Rolle
spielen zum ein weil weil es eben
sozusagen eine investitionskonkurrenz
gibt nenne ich es mal wir sehen es ja
auch aktuell gerade in den Debatten um
den um den haushaltsstopp dass es in
vielen Bereichen fehlende Investitionen
gibt dazu gehört ganz klar die
Verteidigung aber dazu gehört natürlich
beispielweise auch die Digitalisierung
die Bildung die Infrastruktur und die
Frage ist eben in wie fern werden dort
Ausgaben gegeneinander aufgespielt
gegeneinander aufgerechnet und wir
müssen und das ist keinerlei ein ke in
keiner Weise ein neues Phänomen in
Deutschland oder gar insbesondere in den
ostdeutschen teilen dass die Debatte
über Russland über die Ukraine über
Osteuropa eigentlich viel mehr eine
Projektionsfläche ist also dass wenn
Menschen beispielsweise ihre Opposition
zur Ukraine oder ihren Skepsis gegenüber
die ukrainekrieg oder die Unterstützung
hier ausdrücken oder eben ja
unterschiedliche Arten von
proorussischen Überzeugung das ist
häufig viel mehr um eine Art
äh systemopposition hier in Deutschland
geht und darum die die ja also die
Unzufriedenheit mit dem System hier in
Deutschland auszudrücken mhm wir haben
ja eine Frage aus der Community da sagt
jemand auf Youtube der Westen hatte
eigentlich nie eine geschlossene
Strategie das war ist das Problem seit
Beginn des Krieges würden sie da
mitgehen
also ich würde zum ich würde zum Teil
mitgehen in dem Sinne dass man die sich
wirklich drängenden Aufgabe od das
Ausmaß dieser Aufgaben eigentlich nicht
angenommen hat also man hat einerseits
schon eine große Solidarität mit der
Ukraine bezeugt und hat die Ukraine
massiv unterstützt man hat Sanktionen
gegen Russland erlassen und das
sicherlich in einem Ausmaß was noch kurz
vor
Beginn der Invasion so nicht für möglich
gehalten worden wäre aber
nichtdestotrotz ist es eben so dass wenn
wir auf die konkreten Schritte schauen
also beispielsweise den Aufbau
militärischer Produktion um der Ukraine
überhaupt so einen langfristigen Krieg
zu ermöglichen dass das eigentlich etwas
ist wo wir nicht das gemacht haben was
wir hätten machen müssen und dass ich
das natürlich jetzt zu einem gewissen
Maße auch recht deswegen würde ich sagen
so ja die Frage ist ist das Glas halb
voll halb leer ich tendiere ja zu halb
leer um ehrlich zu
sein lassen Sie uns mal auf die andere
Seite dieses Krieges schauen wir haben
sie in Beit hat gerade schon gehört äh
Russland bzw der Kremmel hat heute
reagiert können Sie uns das noch mal
erläutern noch mal analysieren wie
blickt jetzt der Kremmel auf dieses
treffen heute auf dieses ja wie es da
bezeichnet wurde betteln von
selenski also Russland bereitet sich
eigentlich seit Beginn des Krieges und
seitdem sich auch abgezeichnet hat dass
ein schneller Erfolg der Invasion nicht
möglich ist auf einen wirklich lang
anhaltenden Krieg und einer langern
haltende Konfrontation vor wir sehen
eine Umstellung der Wirtschaft auf
kriegsbedürfnisse wir sehen das aber
beispielsweise auch im kulturellen
Bereich in Russland und das Kalkül
dahinter ist dass man den Westen dass
man die Ukraine am Ende aussetzen kann
und am Ende die westliche Unterstützung
für die Ukraine sich zumindest
verkleinern wird wenn ich aussetzen wird
und wenn man dann jetzt eben solche
Debatten sieht und vor allen Dingen
sieht dass die Hilfe für die Ukraine zum
spielpall innenpitischeer Interessen
wird dann fühlt man sich daran natürlich
bestätigt und dann ist das etwas was man
auch sehr gerne in den russischen Medien
zeigt um eben zu bedeuten dass man Ende
eigentlich über die Ukraine und über den
Westen ob siegen wird mhm wir haben zum
Schluss noch eine Frage aus der
Community die sich sicher viele von
unseren Zuschauern und Zuschauerin immer
wider stellen wir sprechen ja jetzt
immerhin schon mehr als anderthalb Jahre
ein dreiviertel Jahre über diesem Krieg
die Ukraine hat nach zwei Jahren Krieg
immer noch nicht alle Waffen bekommen
die es für einen Sieg bräuchte warum
sollte sich das noch
ändern das ist eine sehr gute Frage also
ich hoffe ehrlich gesagt dass sich die
Erkenntnis durchsetzt dass die Ukraine
diesen Krieg gewinnen muss und vor allen
Dingen auch am Ende Russland in
irgendeiner Form diesen Krieg verlieren
muss weil es eine andere langfristige
Lösung dieses Konfliktes nicht
geben wird weil und das wird ja auch
beispielsweise besprochen ein Minsk 3 am
Ende nur ein aufwärmalter Probleme wäre
m die Frage ist natürlich inwiefern
dringt es in den entsprechenden Stellen
durch also beispielsweise in der
deutschen Bundesregierung aber auch in
äh in anderen Regierungen in Europa und
in den USA und da muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen blicke ich aktuell auch mit Sorge
drauf Frau pagung vielen Dank dass Sie
meine Fragen und die Fragen unserer
Zuschauer und zuschauerinn beantwortet
haben trotz diesem pessimistischen
Ausblick wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend ich ihn auch danke schön
danke ich gucke hier noch mal in die
Kommentare und lese da so Sachen wie
Georg Zapf der auf Youtube sagt ich bin
enttäuscht vom Westen und ein anderer
User auf YouTube sagt dass wir die
Ukraine so mies unterstützt haben werden
wir alle noch bitter bezahlen wie es mit
diesem Treffen weitergeht bzw was die
ganz konkreten Ergebnisse sind auch der
Pressekonferenz mit beiden wie es in der
Ukraine an der Front weitergeht ihr
werdet auf jeden Fall darüber informiert
wie immer hier bei ZDF heute live ich
freue mich wenn ihr das nächste Mal
wieder einschaltet und wünsche euch noch
einen schönen
[Musik]
Abend